besides TV work and obviously it was
incredibly difficult but what's the one
role that you can recall in your career
that was the hardest on you physically
mentally the hardest part to play and
then the most
[Music]
rewarding the rewarding part could be a
different role yeah they're they're all
different that way though like for
instance Law and Order was so rewarding
because I was a better actor at the end
of it but it's definitely not worth the
money you know the the the trouble it it
the pressure it put on my family and the
pressure it put on me and it was
definitely not worth the money and so I
don't feel the only reward I got from
that was I was a better actor which is a
pretty good reward yeah you know um the
full metal jacket was will always be my
favorite experience because it was my
first experience you know in in a in a
real film you know like a with the with
a top director like if not one of the
best in the world ever yeah
um I have to say the part that I'm
playing now that I started on Netflix
the Daredevil show is um it's a he's a
crazy this guy like he's so
like real and emotional and he's like a
big baby and a monster at the
same time and it's very you know we have
on the Netflix show as well we had the
opportunity to put him in somewhat
normal situations he fell he fell in
love he got married um in in in the in
the new stuff we're doing he's in normal
situations as well so the play even in
Hawkeye and and in in Hawkeye not so
much but in Eko and in which is not out
yet which precedes the new Daredevil
born again show the we he's in positions
in um where like he was in Netflix where
he's the same guy but he's in a very
normal position and to play him in a
normal position like in a normal
environment like you or I would be in is
just batshit crazy it's like so
hard to do and so crazy
and the that's going on in my mind
when the camera is rolling is just
batshit stuff like honestly like
i' I've get to the point
where wait to see this man do you do you
like when you're rehearsing it do you
rehearse it in a room where there's
nobody else and just kind of lash out do
you have somebody you read the scenes
with and really give it all or are you
just quiet about it and do your own
thing and then and figure that on
set I no I I I have a plan and then most
of that plan goes out the window this is
very normal right that's always happens
with the actors just you know and so but
I have a huge I always have a big plan
coming in and and I don't push it on
anybody if I feel like the blocking is
throwing the scene
off um and we're pushing against it and
pushing I'll try and I'll try and I'll
try and I'll say I'll just stop and I'll
say I don't know if everybody agrees or
not but I just want to put something out
there we're we're pushing up against the
blocking in this scene we need to change
the blocking and then it's like a breath
of fresh air like everybody's like
thank God like yes let's change
it and then we change it and then the
scene starts rocking you know and uh you
got to have guts to do that and I
learned from the best that you have to
have guts um some of my peers are
amazing at stuff like that and like
Ethan Hawk Ethan Ethan Ethan's in search
of the scene constantly and if you're
pushing up against it like he he says
right away no like let's just you know
like this is not right I've been in
scenes acting with him that he's done
that and he's been in scenes acting when
I've done it and I've he's been I've
been directed by him and so you have to
be there
but but no I stay very very calm even if
uh but but just before you know because
we've been on sets for a long time and
we know when thing when you're about to
roll like I get a sense immediately my
radar picks up I got five maybe 10
minutes here before we start roll and
that's when I go in so the ACT doesn't
really mean anything to me I'm already
in by the time the director says action
I'm there so wherever I got to be I mean
I can get ferocious on set like I can be
ferocious and loud and emotional and
like I don't give a what people
think like honestly because you're
getting into it you don't give a I
don't give a h i whether it's
crying or Screaming or or laughing or
whatever the it is you know Cru are
me are taught not to put their hand in
the cage anyway I mean so what the
you know and and so love this man I love
it and I and I just I I just go um yeah
I go all the way so by the time action
is said I'm right when action I'm there
with dialogue boom I'm in like totally
in I love wow but I but most of the time
I spend on set is is calm and sociable
and and uh I'm just you
know pass it's about the homework you
know it's about your homework it is if
you do your homework if you put in the
time learn your lines and do your
homework figure out the scene know where
you were know where you are know where
you're going if you've done all your
analysis of the story that
you're telling then you can show up at
work and have a great time and
then when you know the camera is going
to start rolling you go where you need
to go